teilweise erst muss ich vielleicht
müssten journalisten besseres gespür
entwickeln meint mir wird es keine reise
der spd max wie wollt ihr denn bei den
umfragen gewinnen so und jetzt mal ganz
ehrlich wenn wir uns mal drauf
vereinbaren dass wir manche umfragen
gucken sondern dass wir mutig und auf
ideen und die frage wie kommen menschen
im land an
man hat das ja vielleicht andere wirkung
dessen gerade einen politiker denen ganz
viele abgeschritten mit sonnenstrom hat
es jetzt passt wieder muss man ja sagen
beschafft ins weiße haus zurückzukehren
rädern zu bleiben sondern das ist etwas
ruhig auch als sozialdemokrat sage geben
uns mal nicht auf in deutschland wir
haben noch viel vor und herren werden
jetzt konsequent arbeiten sind und das
ist glaube ich das was ich daraus für
eine lehre für mich ziel
man muss den kandidaten haben man muss
das programm haben dann muss man auch
überzeugt und konsequent sagen wir gehen
jetzt unseren weg und wir lassen uns
nicht abbringen von dem was menschen
links und rechts erzählen sondern wir
wollen werden so dass wir richtig halten
aber nochmal zu der frage wer die
menschen die mehrheit wirklich gut
versteht werden gespür dafür hat dann
werfen wir meinetwegen alle zusammen
politiker journalisten umfrageinstitute
und so weiter kann es damit
zusammenhängen dass eben viele von denen
keinen richtigen alltag mehr haben
zumindest nicht den alltag leben den
ganz viele menschen auf dem land leben
das ist etwas muss man sich wirklich
organisiert werden muss
aber ich mache das jetzt seit zwölf
jahren konsequent jeden sommer von
haustür zu haustür und redet dort mit
den menschen nehmen wir diese zeit und
ich habe schon häufig erlebt dass so
mancher journalist in berlin belächelt
hat warum ein generalsekretär der tür zu
tür geht oder damals nur der bundestag
heute aber ich sage ihnen da hat man
kontakt da kriegt man mit was bewegt die
menschen und das sind manchmal recht
häufiger ganz andere themen als die
dinge die uns herumtragen